[Music]
subscribed him there uh merch
this is not a joke I honestly had to
look this up to make sure it wasn't
somebody [ __ ] with me
oh yeah no Herschel Walker really is
running for setting no just found that
out I know it's mind-blowing it's
astonishing
you like vampires I mean I want you to
keep the faith
oh you ever watch a stupid movie late at
night hoping gonna get better don't get
better but you keep watching it anyway
it's praying your family feels about
your CTE
because the other night the other night
I was watching this movie I was watching
this movie called Fright Night free
night or some type of night but it was
about vampires I don't know if you know
vampires and cool people are they not
this sounds like an Aqua Teen bit can I
please
look I I prayed for fetterman and God
gave me I need Walker we need Walker
Lord Jesus please please we need walk I
know that runoff come on you've given me
a lot this year some stuff I've asked
for some stuff I haven't I know I'm
pushing my luck yeah but please can we
please have Senator Herschel Walker can
we have Walker fetterman in the Senate
and it's a runoff race which is great
because we'll find out right around
Christmas time so it'll be a really nice
little Christmas present to find out
we've got two years of man you ever
watch the old vampire movies
freak not fight not something like that
anyway the Vampire movie is like a
vampire but they'd be biting people
right that kind of cool you think
Michael Strahan shows up he's like man
you make him you're making this all look
stupid really setting up really setting
out people back man you know I've been
to space I've been doing polar bear
stuff you got to educate and expand your
mind polar bear stuff because if you're
not constantly trying to better yourself
you're just gonna stay in the same place
you're gonna be [ __ ] I mean I know I
found [ __ ] but I've been to space
foreign
I just have funny teeth and a lift but
I'm not an idiot but y'all walking
menstrual show yeah I can remember a
Playbook
Empire I don't know if you know vampires
and cool people are they not but I'm
gonna tell you something that I found
out a werewolf could kill a vampire did
you know that I never knew that so I
didn't want to be a
okay look and he I don't I he sounds
like he's wrong but I don't know enough
about valeros and vampires to correct
him I need him
filibuster in the center like this is
what I need I need to Bro imagine
Herschel Walker
as a tool for the for the Republican
party to just exhaust Democrats whenever
they want to debate a bill and it's like
yeah Herschel Walker you now you have
the floor for 30 minutes so I thought
the vampire moved the other night not
vampires and they're like oh he's in the
vampire thing and even Rand Paul's like
can you hurry you know no Rand Paul
would be quietly Shake laughing like
look this is hilarious like and they
have to sit here and listen to this
probably anymore I want to be a werewolf
but then
anyway so I'm watching my TV imagine
imagine that hearings when it's uh yeah
it's uh Dr fauci
um as the studies come out and show uh
that the effectiveness of the vaccine
has actually gone down and caused
reinfection and they've linked long
covet to the vaccine uh will you walk
back your statements uh regarding you
know masks lockdown like Rand Paul's
just laying in the fouchy and they're
like all right uh and now Senator Walker
please
uh Dr fasci thank you
um can a vampire kill a werewolf or can
a werewolf kill a vampire
I don't know how to answer that question
I don't uh I'm not really the guy to ask
about a vampire as a werewolves
Senator van helsings you're sitting
there like it's my time it's finally my
time I've been waiting 1500 years
[Music]
well actually the Rand Paul stands for
them I have the answer [ __ ] you have
Rand Paul's chewing on the end of his
glasses actually the data on vampires
here
does he have everything
for Dr funchi can a Dracula get the code
punchy
what if what if the the werewolf what if
the vampire gets covered it gives it to
the werewolf werewolf dies then
technically the vampire would have
killed the werewolf no oh my God
oh and what's up with that mummy
like what's his deal
[Laughter]
I need this in my life if we're gonna
burn this country down and go back to
making it funny it's got to be this he's
watching their TV uh vampire kill on
their TV do you understand he's he's
still doing the vampire bit dude
this is a two minute and 18
to vampires you think I was kidding this
is the wildest thing you're ever gonna
see in politics
I mean the moment just toilet paper you
just set it on fire is this is this is
this is
and also like Herman Munster was he
supposed to be some kind of Frankenstein
monster but I thought Frankenstein only
made one monster
and then he died right so
if he died why come we got a family why
come we got family
Herschel Walker and giraffes existing on
this planet to prove God
so you know it's kind of stupid but I'm
still watching though as I'm watching
this show yeah it's stupid all right
this kid had a vampire in that attic at
their house
so they were watching their TV
now I'm watching my TV are they watching
their TV or they see the Vampire killer
on that TV so they win this contest to
bring this actor now y'all got to stay
with me bring this actor is he just
describing the entire plot to Fright
Night yes yes
oh okay I mean think about it again this
is brilliant Because by the end of it
you've run out the clock and everybody's
like wow I got to meet Herschel Walker
that's cool
don't say anything too controversial
yeah how is a rehearsal Walker thing you
know I've learned a lot more about
vampires than I expected honestly I
thought it was going to zero about
vampires not TV to get rid of this
really real life vampire in the Attic so
it just acted crazy at home
and then you gotta wonder the the
Godzilla and that whole category of
monsters do they fit in with the other
monsters like as far or they different
genre
he got all the right stuff because I
know I gotta have one of several of the
universal movie Monsters next I will be
talking about the Swamp Thing let's talk
about the Creature from the Black Lagoon
now if you ever in water don't go too
deep y'all the Black Lagoon monster you
grab your feet
grab your feet you'll grab your feet
kill him in the heart and he got a
necklace I used to call the bathwater
after I was done the Black Lagoon okay
guys I want to emphasize that we're now
like a minute and a half in and he's
still talking about a vampire movie
like this is a senator I want to point
out too this is a guy running for
Senator one of the 15 most powerful
people in the world he's in a deadlocked
race right now and they have to go to a
runoff election where it's basically a
do-over election this is going to decide
who has control of the Senate basically
and he's this is literally for control
of the Senate is on the line and we
backed Herschel Walker and now he's out
here mumbling about vampires for two
minutes I love that I don't I don't want
things to be any different this is the
weirdest honest question when we started
doing this show like with 2017 right
things were weird if I would have told
you in 2017 hey my one day we're going
to be doing a show and Herschel Walker
we're running for Senate talking about
vampires you believe me because I
wouldn't believe me I wouldn't believe
me by 2018 I would have believed you
okay but 2017. 2017 I probably wouldn't
have believed by 2018 I would have been
like yeah with all the [ __ ] that's
happening probably or if you got a
necklace of garlic for that work I don't
know what it does but it worked gotta
have a cross because it burned I know
that worked and then all of a sudden
this is what was so funny about it gotta
have some garlic because I know that
word another it shouldn't have been a
minute of vampire facts just give it a
second walking through the house there's
a minute of this left
this is absolutely [ __ ] insane to me
now vampires hail from a place called
Transylvania I ain't sure if that
let me tell you something hear me listen
Georgia listeners if you didn't vote or
you forgot please the runoff is coming
please please everything you can needs
to go into making sure this man gets
there because this is the owner this is
our counter to fetterman right this is
our counter this is our only play that
we have this is we we need this this is
amazing I need Herschel Walker and
fetterman singing Ebony and Ivory
king of all pixels you said in all caps
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
vampire movies obviously wow
unbelievable he doesn't know what he's
talking about he's being very clear
about it so let me get this straight you
don't pay attention to the man talking
and then he's the [ __ ] yeah oh wow
when you
when you're parting your attic
I'm trying to help you [ __ ] oh no what
do I do he told you what to do you
weren't listening garlic crosses because
they burn apparently I didn't know that
yeah
they walked upstairs and this vampire
looking real good in this black suit
whoa
vampire was a dying piece Papa
oh that sounds like Senator Warner
well what was Senator Warnock is a
vampire bro is he climbing me he's
jamming your boy's clamming you what is
what is this please I gotta he's he's
all right look I have no obviously no
love for the demo for homo Thugs and no
no definitely not for all my friends but
I have no love there's no love lost here
with the Democrats on my end uh but and
Senator Warnock I'm sure is just part of
that shitty machine of course he is but
he's also like a really well spoken very
respected man he's the head of the
church that Martin Luther King used to
be the best of
um and he's very well I thought that
wasn't Langley
sounds like Senator or not doesn't it
looking all good
do you have any comments on Herschel
Walker's accusation that you were a
creature of the night
how many people's blood have you sucked
uh Senator Warnock
put it from the ceiling he floated from
the ceiling looking good and cool and
I'm thinking whoa they better get out of
that house if somebody float he's doing
the joke that you do like at the oh you
better get out of that house in a black
and you know the black guy in the movies
you better leave I love him what was the
Halloween movie with Busta Rhymes
I need him and fetterman
like bipartisan anything some kind of
take it together for your ceiling get
out of that
out your house but as he floated from
the ceiling the kid jumped behind that
hero and they jumped behind that hero
the guy jumped in front of him with this
holy world Threw It On The Vampire
forehead he covered his eye I can't I
can't take his hand away he started
laughing and he said that don't work he
took the cross he put it on the vampire
forehead and the vampire didn't even do
anything he said that bro robotics he
goes I'm in Georgia and I'm totally
voting for him on December 6. just so I
can get more vampire talk thank you no
no no this isn't a joke we're not joking
TV Silver Wing Senator Warnock are you
willing to wear this garlic amulet
I mean just the proof I mean if you wear
it then we know I mean if you're not
going to wear it
and then he just refuses like no I'm not
wearing it also you are a vampire I am
yelling garlic
by the way can I say that not only does
he give us money but the local
subscribers shot is the funniest chat
holy [ __ ] garlic amulet that don't work
and that's the way it is in our life
it's not even working unless you got
faith it is time for us to have faith we
got to have faith in our fella bro I
love the fact that this man I want to
point this out again Senate rates so
close in a deadlock they need to do a
runoff election
bad Herschel what van hurt leaning mean
thank you lean and me they're literally
doing a runoff uh election in a dead
dead heat [ __ ] race for the senate
seat that will take control of the
Senate
and the man who's up to get the
Republican side spent last night
watching fright night instead of working
on a speech
and then he just decided I'll just come
in
that he's seen several times by the way
I'm just gonna talk about Friday night
I'll wing it Mr Walker you're sure we
have a speechwriter you sure will this
[ __ ] is treating the the future
of the Senate like the way I treat like
a Thursday night wave when I don't have
enough
a lot of body cam footage same thing I'm
coming and wing it
there's a lot of body cam day waves so I
was watching this video with this black
man getting tased
this is gregoromo underworld evolution
we've got Herschel with the uh with the
necklace of garlic
this is so stupid will you wear this
garlic ambulance [ __ ] murdered me
that's what I'm saying it's the garlic
necklace okay let me get that let me get
the garlic Ah that's very funny hey
Senator why don't uh why don't I fix
your hair in front of this mirror if you
vote for me I'll remove all the vampires
from Georgia
holy [ __ ] I see I was looking for the
mirror joke
I know you I know you weren't my my joke
was very was very similar
um this is his proof uh this is this is
how he this is how hold on let me pull
this up uh
that garlic necklace is so I mean also
have they really specified how much
garlic you need to keep a vampire weight
you need a lot or a little because I
mean I I would imagine it's more a
matter of like I think you'd want to cut
open the garlic right
here this is worn this is this is why he
thinks this is Warnock looking at his
own reflection and he is not one so
that's why
that's he right yeah there he is there
he is
or is that wait that might be John Cena
might be Johnson is John Cena a vampire
there's really there's really no way to
know I mean you do have to invite him
into the Make-A-Wish thing so probably